le mot maquée par exemple moi je le
trouve formidable parce qu'il ya de fait
plein de gens disent oh je suis mac et
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire makheia
2 il ya deux acceptions à ce terme soit
ça veut dire je suis mangé
donc je suis en train de me faire
digérer et je serai bientôt chier pardon
d'être vulgaire mais c'est çà et là
deuxième acception du ter c'est je suis
mac et j'ai un maquereau c'est à dire
voilà je suis prise en main jeu et je
vais faire rentrer de l'argent par les
moyens de vous savez et ça ça ne fait
pas envie
si vous voulez moi ça ne me fait pas
envie et je comprends pas pour 10 de son
plein gré je suis mac et où je suis casé
casey c'est pareil un casey c'est la
case à la maison donc mon amour en fait
c'est les murs du foyer et on ne peut
pas en sortir
vous avez aussi l'enterrement de vie de
garçon l'enterrement de vie de jeune
fille
moi je trouve ça fascinant ce truc avant
se marier on s'enterre c'est à dire
qu'on enterre la liberté qu'on avait et
ensuite qu'est ce qu'on fait on va poser
un cadenas d'amour un jeu tous les gens
qui habitent paris où ont visité paris
connaissent ça vous avez des ponts
entier qui sont recouverts de cadenas
sens est censée symboliser de l'amour
éternel mais qu'est ce qui symbolise le
plus la captivité qu'un cadenas
ouais je pose la question
[Musique]